hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer question
from one of my readers Mohammed who
wrote in he's got a new website called
good or great idea and the premise here
is if you're a startup entrepreneur you
can post your idea people can comment on
it online rated you can potentially ask
for funding get partnerships and it
sounds like a great idea it's really
going to depend on the people that you
get into the system to see if it's going
to take off for now the technology is
not so complicated so we will get in the
community so we'll go check out the site
so what happens here when you load a web
site is you'll see a random idea so it's
pretty simple site here you'll have a
random startup idea that shows up on the
site my issue here is that it may not be
a quality idea so I just loaded this one
up and this person wants to start a
neighborhood bulletin board and you know
the description is is pretty weak they
write probably already been done but
heck is just an idea just warming up
here unique value proposition nothing
really should I just delete this dumb
idea not looking for teammates not look
for funding so this probably should not
be on the system and if I'm a first-time
person coming to the website I'm
probably not going to have a good
opinion of a good or great idea just
looking at this idea so what happens
here is random so every time I hit the
site again you'll get a different idea
and so some may be better than others
but what I would probably do is try to
organize them by ones that have gotten
some votes and are you don't trending
and are looking for funding and have
filled it out or maybe have some kind of
quality guidelines so you don't get
people saying this is a dumb idea I
should delete it and they have no unique
value proposition so I'd be kind of my
first step is looking at profile in the
home page so that when you're a first
time visitor it looks like there's
something valuable here the top 10
innovators here are shown on the left
and I guess these are entrepreneurs who
are posting their their ideas I don't
know how much value there is here I
guess that you can look at their profile
and see what's going on
so nothing is really showing up here all
right um so again I don't know how
useful this is going to be for people
the judges would be interesting if they
were maybe a little bit more high
profile so the top judge I mean these
guys have have their own names so bling
bling idea Queen if I'm an entrepreneur
and I want to be judged them idea I
would want to see that you know you have
some venture capitalist on here people
who could potentially fund my idea so
the top one is a guy named Mohammed look
at his profile and so this is muhammad
and he is an enterprise sales person for
IBM so ok great but you know ideally if
i'm an entrepreneur if i was posting my
idea here i'd want to see that there's
some other kind of investor behind here
that might be able to give my my idea
some actual you know credibility so the
judging you might want to improve a
little bit on the judging system to get
better judges on board somebody who's
might be brand name it could also help
promote the site the biggest competition
i think for you is going to be sites
like Kickstarter so if we take this one
off and go to kickstarter.com and this
is a system built for entrepreneurs
people to raise money right away I see
that they've been featured on their
press so it looks like they're high
quality they show a whole bunch of
different projects and either ones that
I've already had some good money pledged
and are closing in on being funded so if
i refresh it it won't be that different
every time I come back and it's it gives
me a kind of good sense it gives me more
options so I may not like the first idea
but I can scroll down and see other
ideas as well we're here I may not know
that this is a random idea I only kind
of discovered it because I can rotate it
and see a new one coming up so I don't
know if after seeing one bad idea if I
would have an incentive to want to post
it or not so it's definitely an
interesting idea there's a couple of
sites that are coming up that are
following this model I think there's
opportunity it's more about getting the
right entrepreneurs on board
who want to post it and i think that
would come from a trying to attract some
good judges some venture capitalists and
people in the media who could lend their
credibility to it so that when
somebody's actually judging your idea
you get somebody who is well respected
and could potentially give you money if
if they like your idea so that might be
a good step to kind of get you going and
then maybe on the homepage showcase some
of the better ideas that people get a
good impression of you the first time
they come and they're more willing to
want to stick around and then also I
guess if you've gotten any kind of media
to put it on here because I don't really
see that you've gotten some media and if
you haven't then maybe you want to write
to some outlets and try to get profile a
little bit as well so I hope that helps
Mohamed oh maybe this is you here
Muhammad very active if you have any
questions then be happy to answer them
and anybody else if you want to leave a
comment below the video and I always
appreciate it when you leave a thumbs up
so please leave those that lets me know
you like the videos and I'll keep making
more so thank you and stay tuned for
next episode
you